pour cette recette aussi belles que
bonnes que des fruits qui vont être
travaillées par le chef johan lepage et
son élève chloé cavale del valle
on va réaliser avec des fruits frais un
petit gâteau de fruits en assemblage on
va éplucher pour ça une orange avis une
poire une pomme golden un kiwi et un
ananas
on va retirer les deux entames de
l'ananas et ensuite avec notre couteau
on va épouser la forme de l'ananas de
faire en sorte que l'on voit plus les
yeux sur l'ananas
on va faire la même chose avec une
orange va enlever les deux entames pour
la stabilité sur la planche et ensuite
avec un petit couteau
on va venir épluchez oranges à vif
ensuite sur le range on va prélever les
segments
c'est à dire qu'on va passer notre lame
de couteau entre les deux petite
membrane qui sépare le segment d'orange
et on va prélever des petits segments
donc on va monter un petit entremets de
ce diamètre là pour ça il va nous
falloir une base pour pouvoir déplacer
d'entre eux mais on va prélever cette
base dans une belle tranche d'ananas je
vais faire une base pour moi c'est une
base pour chloé
mettre à plat sur la planche à découper
avec l'emporte-pièce le cercle on va
emporte-pièce et de forme
pour faire des tranches relativement
fine pour qu'on puisse les plier si vous
fait d'étranges trop épaisse on
n'arrivera pas à ça tu es un cintre et
la tranche sans la casser
donc là les tranches assez fine dans la
pomme golden opus les plier aux gens
prendre un petit peu
[Musique]
on prend pas les tranches avec les
pépins donc on va prendre des demi
tranche pour les regrouper en deux
ensuite avec une pince ou avec la pointe
d'un couteau on va disposer nos tranches
de pommes contre le cercle
mon chat en rosace tout loto on va faire
la brunoise avec les parures si on a des
petits morceaux comme ça qu'on ne peut
pas utiliser ni à la mandoline
on peut réaliser une petite brunoise
c'est à dire quoi faire des tout petits
cubes
très régulier et on peut faire un
mélange de fruits on fait comme si on
faisait une mini salade de fruits
conviendra disposés en décor sur notre
gâteau à la fin on prélève de trois
petites feuilles jolie ou les sommités
des cercles et tout est prêt vous avez
fait deux gâteaux différents voilà d'où
vient ton différent avec les mêmes
fruits que du fruit et du fruit frais
ils zéro calorie en trois
[Rires]